what's that belief nation happy weekend
it's time to open some more of your
packages
[Music]
all right super coming to be here again
happy weekend guys hopefully you've been
having an amazing one you guys are set
horse stuff and so we're going to open
them give some shoutouts and for those
of you who want to potentially be on a
future video with your product we're
going to link up the address to the
description below send it in and you
never know you might be featured on this
channel with a link to your website as
well let's get started first up let's do
this Antoine so swine runs a company
called do Buddha we did a collaboration
together heartburn okay oh there's no
card there is no part isn't good it's
just for evidence a melis lon with no
guard huh nice [ __ ] it up nice no that's
my eye feels really good on you wait did
I get another one no one I lost my other
hat this is a hot let's hug it at
someone and he brought me one when we
went to film but it was too small and so
affluent haha were filming with him I
had this line across her head and a
headache so I said can you give me a
bigger one of my wear it until he sent
it to me yeah looks better but now I
lost a hat farnborough I knew another
one any another one please here's
another one I just walked into the life
break and then oh so he's either his
t-shirt let's hug it out and one is for
Haven and won it for you Oh penetrated
stuff happening on the other side of the
camera you're that let's hug it out oh
let's hug it out I think when I first
like a roaring its future oh let's hug
it out I think you there you go and
you've got the hot it looks good this
one is still unclear you think it's mine
yeah eventually I like the box let's
take us a black guy dude Buddha how it
works all right Titus chest but
I'm feeling I born here I'm feeling you
too and I'm wearing it check it it's so
sticky ah next put your um what do we
get what we go oh wait it thank you
pretty good really good take it oh I see
my face what is that what is this oh
this is mmm thank you honey look at that
Thank You Evan for all you do for our
hashtag believe I let the toothless from
them Valerie Pugsley hold until tomorrow
you can look at all this look at that
Holly wrote a nice message everything
people you do support your community
here you are my lunchtime break from the
computer especially in jersey expresso
as a lunch and learn serious much
inherent luncheon burn although I
haven't done that for a while at first I
could resonate with your one more
concept but oblate I'm starting to play
with it and I've landed on the word
serve serve I like it I've left a few
comments this is is a solution for you
on some of your videos but I mostly
watch it on my smart TV and I don't you
should comment but you're having an
impact Thank You Valerie Pugsley I love
it ok let's open it up and see what we
got this is cool let's take that what we
have that's happening you don't like
that kinda cute wish Thank You sheriff
dark chocolate you're lying side dark
chocolate gourmet fudge brownie my mouth
with water and lemon kid Calvin dry ok
Carolyn shows up with a Valerie
hopefully we're going to share your
brownie Humpty on a diet so I'm going to
try a little bit
oh hey how was it you may be live it
less the chunky chocolate yummy mm-hmm
lose it later Thank You Valerie all
right next what's this Gabriel round
last time I had all those books what's
the Hat is still working through my bush
I don't think that quickly good oh the
pond by Gabriel Brown do that that seems
oh that's a thing but no look at these
notes look at that handwritten notes 07
Carmichael anyone gave you get real
brown pen name actually a comment a
comment under your video sometimes as
Gabriel ether I hope that you enjoy both
you mentioned one of your videos that
since you have a lot on your plate but
people should just tell you what page to
go to that's beautifully yeah all those
it's book as simple does is easy to read
I think when I actually say the word
believe it are the very last page of the
story but the entire book is about
believing in yourself and you can please
a book is very short anyway also is so
trouble to both whether or not i should
send this book to you by having so many
errors but unfortunately cannot fix the
errors at this time due to my current
situation my book has a still a bunch of
errors after i went to a thousand times
my editor the copy editor still has
there's only six ms edition so those you
can buying it now as you get the the
rare version i started send because the
grammar science it'll be no problem
reading it I'm a perfectionist so I'm
very disturbed had some moments at the
amount of very recent titles but I
couldn't risk not sending at all because
the opportunities of greater love your
videos and are expected work can you put
in them I know that I have a great book
i know it will help many people the
circles even in themselves give them
brown thanks for the love the pawn the
pond that's an angry face look at how
angry that cases look at that angry pond
the pond all right
with excellent comment Allen Muhammad
Ali Ali others a week Muhammad Ali's
been in something phenomenal so oil
packs down this 56 of oil pastels there
no no no did we talk about oil pastel no
I don't know what is that what it has
its to make art oh yeah look at all come
on color look at all that well I don't
know what prompted this but thank you
Muhammad Ali I appreciate it next up our
Finley from Saint Paul college winnipeg
manitoba oh it's another and oh I rip
the lighter side rosemary sorry rosemary
broke your letter dear mr. comics I'm
writing on behalf of my friends on
Andreas de la casa aundrea smith said
you are familiar with his name I
represent his artwork to the past few
years on a pro bono basis his to exist
in canada hopeless work of muses and
stimulates you rosemary finland has to
be more careful it's art it's their art
art art art we got high
how long what out the thing without I
will seduce them that's it thank you
enjoy it appreciate the love this is
from mar 10 what are we go oh wow whoo
oh that that's such what how do not feel
that I nobody's I packed a punch maybe
I'm in sick I'm always healthy lemon no
no your hands of beer what did you put
on that ah no no different good emotion
mix of lotion no no different
what is it holy I create my day that to
having in the belief team thank you for
inspiring us rose and rafts attend any
and all feedback on my products are
welcome but what is the product senses
heart oh cheese is the little thing okay
yeah this is it this is what smelling
tabula rasa lemon is the first
ingredient yeah listen Syd a wife that's
placed and lemons the first thing you
should know I was throwing the
experiment that's what I was knowing how
to cause experiment that's like her
let's penny per second let's open up his
heart like we got like a bunch of these
cards oh the stuff on the box
mindfulness mantra and daily meditation
oh this up on the front to harness the
power of positivity I see the gifts and
everyone and everything I intoxicant
compassion I am bundled League West
looks like affirmation I know today will
be amazing
and create my day see I allow myself to
live the life I want I'm prosperous and
popular endless that we want to leave
please I believe I can yes I believe I
can this is the best one this is my
favorite one this is the best foot in
here I like it thank you thank you jawon
sent the card jiguan was on the channel
we get an espresso or tues together
profiles of one workbook with his
channel which I appreciated this is the
card thank you for giving me an
opportunity to collaborate with you
really this year hopefully we can do it
again soon and I appreciate the advice
suggestions you're giving me on my
friend and on my journey that night my
movement wishing you and your family
awesome season and massive breakthroughs
in 2017 look forward to updating your
concentration keep hashtag believing
anything is hashtag possible your
biggest fan Jay I like it don't work man
boxes oh look at this it says mail time
and this is as Anna Nina on my name is
Kim yes we know i am that i have the Hat
nina doesn't have a hot nina has buttons
oh I like it Tara thank you okay open to
them okay thank you oh look at that i'm
gonna Nina he just made a day I wanted
to reach out you to say thank to use
just a short time ago I was on a cross
one of my life to give up my dreams and
settle for a life in which my body was
determined by others and any job that
would take me or to risk everything for
vision I had of a new invention that
stole my heart I believe that is because
of people like you that have inspired me
to open my mind realize my true
potential and go from my dreams actually
now stand proudly today and say that I
successfully invented this product it is
all that I knew in my heart it would be
I'm so thankful to have been able to
surround myself with wisdom from both of
you Nina job with the wisdom and the
many mentors you features I filled my
mind with speed and now a beautiful
creation has sprouted I just have to go
for I just have to believe kindly
and gratefully satara be terribly there
I like to thank you i'm saving me Oh
another one is that Evan I thank you so
much but this gives us for Nina really
yeah really yeah but if you are sweet
she just might share a tree hahaha
winter time later he didn't take a lot
of my stuff okay so you got the hot Wow
look at that look at that note me don't
stick it why need to be able to read it
Nina you're bright and shiny personality
makes me smile when you're on the videos
patent base I think that you will love
my gifts and the exercise excluded for
you I hope you find that it is helpful
and that it brings an extra smile to
your day as you bring this art PS the
other goodies that I had included are
from a company environment to learn that
have shown me an immense amount of love
and encouragement I feel that there is
nothing to lose your other success but
only positive things the game so if you
like their treats I hope that they could
get a little shout-out to do you have a
ready jump smile to my face you're kind
of tired a little yeah hey this is look
at that another message my key bling
it's time to say bye bye to that boring
string and hello to your new T bling
handmade steel stainless steel clip with
a crystal charm eclipse on any ebay I
drink tea every day hey it looks like
platinum okay my Wow okay Wow yeah
pretty let's show it look at that
especially its Swarovski crystals yeah
you flip this to the tea bag me i just
made a huge mess this is amazing this is
great oh ok I'd be back to me after okay
keep going my okay breathe is a breed
your way through it you should just see
me read your way through it there's a
nice collection of tea but she leaves on
the floor me and I tried to open this
loose tea leaves jump it was a long tea
green tea oh this is her friends company
besties on the go Earl Grey preserved
orange bars oh not so goodness what is
it to talk about the person oh it starts
oh and mob start shopping I'm fine I'm
allergic to chocolate the top is like
Maureen Johnny oh it's okay can I have
one can I try one oh my god kicking it
can I mine hmm look up there mon orange
caramel time ago I don't you live inside
the caramel is crazy I think it's worth
getting the headphones on awesome all
right that keeps on the go thank you I
knew another fight about Oh army would
you put it yeah this is amazing this is
more yeah ohh okk game so with the turn
so what you do is this was a booty in
this bag and then fold it whatever
somehow and then click on this and I put
it in your water oh and have this hang
up got it thank you thank you for the
peach aren't I like it so it's parsley
I'm not going to see that okay next this
says
book one book this is a book this is
from Sandra in Switzerland yeah Andrew
Miller Jane Switzerland all right
cheektowaga ones that want us to contact
this is it look at that okay there's a
bunch of stuff in here we start with
tutorial how to make these different
things but it looks like the one that I
want to do sweet snowflakes Christy you
an idea well that I would be unlucky
guys bridal womens brown with these
crazy chicks hot air balloon kick ass
popcorn yes how to make kick-ass popcorn
put this tutorial look at this tutorial
ingredients and then picture the steps
that you need to take to do it oh my God
look at that popcorn I want to eat that
right now look at this
the melted watering nurse a book and
Ryan Atlas Shrugged anniversary edition
look at the size of this book holy cow
look at how tiny the font is to look at
that that's not how many pages about it
after taking a thousand and 77 to super
thousands there's an inscription okay
dear Evan here is my submission to the
sign books chibi challenge I hope that
you'll like the cookie and I apologize
if it takes a little to drive there but
eat fresh here in the top e of my
favorite book it's a long read but it
has changed my life since reading it
thank you for all that you do your fan
from Switzerland thank you for the book
look at this listen last time it was all
about the book then having all about the
chocolate sweets I like it guys guys if
you have sweets that's part of your
business send it to me we're going to
eat it look at this book is a couple
things here look at these chains I like
you think I'll like look at that what a
business card huh for workshops kicks up
and more kitsch cake stop th-this is
some really beautiful night like this
I'm thinking to an entrepreneur cafe
maybe we have some pitch takes pride in
the internet cafe oh you know what I
didn't know you guys excited she going
really ya know I kind of got to kind of
got messed around but there's this is
crazy i don't want to eat it so in the
in the flight suits which away and it
kind of got messed up a little bit but
there's a little YouTube button there's
our logo and then between and suppress
the coffee and then there's the letters
believe but the letters got messed up
wow this is so amazing should we eat it
I guess it's going to go bad right is
there a way to preserve them I feel like
we need to eat
but I feel bad cuz i wanna i want to see
this take a picture i'm going to take a
picture in nsw you can't really get
young amazin on this is amazing oh it
got your ruin all that your one word
opus of the book this is this is what
how it arrived in the mail very sad oh
that's how it arrives in the mail but it
looks amazing oh another one well before
I move it around we got the plane again
youtube logo and press a logo I don't
think you can save that one see me
you're gonna try okay honey okay I
kalita I believe it's a puzzle I'm
making a puzzle okay so i think the
other one too I think it's that it away
yeah you shouldn't how to sell believe
me and I come in I can't even fix it so
let's see one who knew bullying takes it
so good mm-hmm coming to Switzerland to
learn how to make this that'd be amazing
so thank you guys for watching thank you
for all the awesome gifts I really
appreciate it if you want to send me
something for the next edition of mail
time set of the traveler and salsa the
address is in the description really
appreciate it thank you for the love the
sex will be of an amazing weekend we
believe in you we hope to continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is let's love guys we'll
see you soon
you